Everybody!
Hello, hello.
Welcome to Girls Front Line 2.
Exilium.
I hope I'm pronouncing the last part correctly because like dokey things.
But welcome everyone.
Welcome, welcome.
Let me put this up.
So, a huge shout out to Sunborn and Mika team for sponsoring me today.
For me to check out Girls Front Line 2.
Exilium.
This is my first time playing a Girls Front Line game.
I've never played one before.
I heard that what I was told is that it is a sequel, of course, to Girls Front Line.
And it is a 3D strategy RPG game.
And it features like non-photorealistic rendering and physically based rendering technology.
So, like that's like the main thing.
A lot of the main standpoint regarding this game.
The 3D graphics is apparently really, really good.
And so, I'm super excited to try it out.
If you guys want to support this stream, support this sponsor, support me, please feel free to check out the link in the description and pinned in the chat.
You click the link or download the game.
Even clicking the link helps out a lot in general.
So, I've thought the main selling point was the pretty women.
I mean, what makes them look pretty?
The physically based rendering and the non-photorealistic rendering.
That's what makes them pretty, guys.
It's the technology.
Anyway, so, they do have a new event right now called Escape from Cyborg, as you see here behind me right now.
So, there is the newest event.
And that's why, apparently, I'm going to be checking out.
There are some new characters.
There is some free stuff that's coming out for this new event.
As you know, like a lot of these games, when there's a new event, that means there's new free stuff.
And we all love free stuff.
So, from what I'm told, basically, we take the role of a commander.
And we're leading the pretty women you see here.
They're called Tactical Dolls, T-Dolls.
And then we're leading them through, like, various missions and stuff like that.
And there's a lot of stuff you could do.
There's apparently a dormitory mode, which I was told was something I should really look forward to.
So, I'm excited about that.
I was telling my friends that, like, oh, yeah, they're like, oh, yeah, what are you going to do?
Do you want to play or anything?
I was like, no, I have to do a sponsor stream later.
And they're like, oh, what is it?
And I was like, oh, Girls Frontline 2, Exilium.
And my friends were like, oh, you're going to enjoy it.
And I was like, why?
Oh, when you get to the refitting room, you'll understand.
I was like, refitting room.
I was like, what do you mean by that?
And then my friends are like, you'll understand.
So, I'm looking forward to trying that out.
Anyway, apparently, from this event, there are new dolls that you can gotcha.
So, I believe it's Vector, right?
Vector and what's her name?
How do you pronounce it?
Dush Ivanya?
Is that her other...
Yeah, Vector is apparently incredibly OP at the moment.
Okay, I'm...
I see everybody was like, um, it's actually pronounced this.
I'm like, what do you mean by that?
Okay, I guess I'll find out.
I'm gonna...
Oh, only Vector is new?
Okay, so there's increased drop rates for both of them.
But Vector is the newest one.
And she is apparently incredibly OP.
So, I look forward to getting her.
Because surely my gotcha luck has improved by then, right?
Go ahead, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You had to see Doki in the dorm room?
Um, excuse me.
What do you mean by that?
Anyway, uh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Surely, uh...
Surely, this time, my rates have improved now, right?
Alright, so...
Who knows who don't know?
Like I said, this is like my first time playing this game.
So, obviously, um, I don't know a lot too much about, uh, Girls Frontline 2.
Exilium.
So, I'm learning this game as we go along with the stream.
So, these are all, like, my raw first reactions to everything.
Uh, but other than that...
So, a couple of, like, free stuff that you can get right now for this event is...
There's apparently several new outfits.
So, what is it?
Uh, Colfeen's new outfit.
And Vector's new outfit.
And they are free.
So, uh, as long as you participate in the limit time event...
Uh, you get to, uh, get to get these outfits for free.
Especially for Vector, since she is new.
Um, oh, and her name is Cell...
Cell...
Cell phone.
Oh, like, Colfeen.
I don't know.
That's how I pronounce it.
Um, anyway.
And there's also...
If you sign in every day during this event...
Um, there's, like, a bunch of free things you can get.
So, there's Collapse Pieces.
Next Gen.
700 Collapse Pieces.
7... 14.
Next Gen.
Memory Stick.
10.
Transcription Conductor.
20.
Okay, there's a lot of...
You get a lot of transcription conductors.
There's a lot of them.
I can't read Roman numerals.
Uh...
And there is a redeem code, too.
So, you do Labor Day for your redeem code.
Until...
This is for US servers only, by the way.
Um, and it's gonna be from...
Until May 31st.
And, like, the redeem code is Labor Day.
So, you get free stuff.
And you're like, that's not fair.
I'm not in US...
Just swap to US...
I guess it's time for you to swap to U.S.
servers, guys.
I guess it's time.
Oh, yeah.
So, apparently, it's Golden Week for the other server.
So, what was... which is the other server?
I redeem... so, Labor Day for Dark Winter server.
And then, Golden Week for HowPlay server.
So, there's... use your free codes, guys.
Look at that.
See, you learned something new today.
On my stream.
You learned something new.
Anyway, before we do play the game, I do want to react to several of the videos that were sent to me to see, like, you know, what they're about.
So, let me know, SoundGuy, if the video is too loud or not.
So, this is a release trailer and gameplay trailer.
Like I said, I am going in blind.
I saw a lot of people were like, Eee!
Apparently, it's a famous meme.
We're relating to the Girls Front Line community.
It was crazy.
I saw a lot of people were super hyped for me to try it out.
There were a lot of, like, people in the community that were super hyped to see me check this game out and to see, like, you know, my reaction to it.
And I'm looking forward to seeing what it's like.
All right.
Let's see what the trailer they sent me.
Let me know if it sounds okay, guys.
Oh, they're all so cute.
Oh, my God.
And they're holding some big-ass guns.
I love me some...
V-A-G...
bag.
Oh.
Okay, the 3D graphics is actually really good for 3D.
Oh, fuck.
Eee!
Oh, she's cute.
I like her.
I like her outfit.
Oh, so I...
I know, like I said...
Like, the fact that it's all 3D is really nice.
The rendering, guys!
It's the rendering!
Also, we're playing...
We're gonna be playing...
I'd ask you guys if you guys want to be playing with...
Chinese voice acting or Japanese voice acting.
And we're gonna be playing Japanese voice acting.
Because most people voted for that.
There is no English voice acting for this game.
Yet, I assume.
So it's time to read.
I love reading.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I know her!
Wait, I know this girl!
She's like...
It's like...
She's from Girls Front Line 1, right?
That design, the little cross thing?
I've seen that design before.
Yeah?
She's like really famous.
Yeah, 416.
Mostly everyone's from Girls Front Line 1.
Oh!
I know that girl with the blue cross...
Like the blue medic cross.
Because she was like really famous for a while.
Like her design was everywhere.
Oh, my God.
More camera cuts!
Oh, there's a cake.
There's so many girls!
Which one to choose?
There's so many!
Oh, they're all made...
Using in-game engine?
That's crazy.
They're so pretty.
For in-game.
There's so many girls!
Who will I pick?
I mean, it's easy.
Vector, who I'm definitely gonna get first try.
Oh, there's the...
The gameplay.
Oh!
Nice.
Whoa!
Extra...
What the...
Where did she get the...
The ocean?
I'm trying not to swear.
Where did she get the ocean?
Oh, my God.
Swim style.
Like, I love...
I love the beach episode.
Oh, there's the three...
Is this...
Wait a minute.
Is this the refitting room?
I understand.
Neurons activated.
I understand now.
Oh, that's just the...
Wait, we're not even at the good part!
Those are just the dorms?
Oh, my...
We're not even at the good part.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Oh, ho.
All right.
The new doll.
Okay.
So, the next one is...
The trailer for Vector.
Who is the newest character for this game.
And who we're trying to pull for it.
Huh?
That's a free sample.
I see the vision now.
Oh.
Suddenly, I find myself clicking the link to install Girls Frontline, too.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
I mean, there's...
The guns are really nice, too.
Like, the...
The guns enthusiasts.
Yeah, I heard the community for this game is, like...
Um...
Really strong.
And the, uh...
Some boy in Mika, like, loves to listen to community feedback and stuff.
So, the support for this game is, like...
Um...
I know, like, when I posted in my waiting room, everybody was so excited.
Like, the...
The fan...
The fan interaction for this is really high.
Yeah.
Guns and anime.
The double whammy.
Oh.
Whoa.
She locked in.
Yeah.
For love of waifus.
Oh.
I never thought...
Oh, she uses an SMG.
All right.
So, that's the new character.
That, apparently, everybody wants to get right now.
Because she's incredibly OP.
All right.
I think I can get her.
This time?
For real?
Surely, this time, I can get her.
All right, guys.
So, a huge shout-out to...
Okay, so, like...
Just to be transparent.
A huge shout-out to Sunborn and Mika for...
Providing me an account for this.
So, like...
There's no way I...
Like, because...
You can tell that I have a lot of resources.
So, there's no way...
I can't mess this up this time.
I...
Surely...
There is no way I can mess this up.
If...
If they gave me some resources to try and pull...
Try and pull her.
I...
I swear to God.
Surely.
All right.
So, I believe, obviously, it should be the recruitment, right?
So...
I...
I have enough, I think.
I don't know where...
That's only...
There's no way I can't get her in a hundred pulls.
There's no way.
No sound, by the way.
Okay.
How's the sound right now for the game?
There is sound on my end.
There is...
That's enough.
That's up for not.
There's no way I fail the 50-50.
There is...
Okay.
Let me...
It's just because the game might be a little too quiet.
All right.
I'll boost up the game volume real quick.
Let me know if it's better.
If not, I can boost it up.
No, it's not muted.
It's playing on my screen.
It's just that it might be a little low.
Yeah.
The game might be a little low.
Okay.
Let me boost it up a little bit more then.
All right.
You hear it now?
That's what it sounds like.
Yeah.
It's very quiet.
All right.
So, if I don't...
Also, if you guys want to try your luck, feel free to, as always, like, there is the link to the game in my description and in my chat, pinned in my chat.
So, feel free to check that out, um, to check out the game yourself.
And, you know, maybe your luck will be better than mine, but it won't be because I'm going to get her right now.
You know what?
I have two, right?
I have two extras.
So, like, I might as well do the first two singular polls to prove to you how lucky I am.
I've never seen the animation yet.
Surely.
Quote of the century.
Oh, wait.
Oh, that's a blue.
Blue's not...
Oh, it's a gun.
Wait, I can get guns from this?
Okay.
All right, how's the sound, by the way, from the polls?
All right.
Okay, and then I'll do one more just to show you guys that it will be better.
It will be fine.
All right.
Oh, it's okay.
I'm just getting all the bad luck.
Getting all the guns out of the way.
Now that I got the guns out of the way, I will get Vector in the first ten polls.
Right here.
Now that I got all the guns out of the way, this is where we get the people.
That's a purple.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's...
I got the purple out of the way.
I got...
It's okay.
What is she?
Oh?
Oh, she's cute.
Wait, I love her hat.
It's so cute.
Wait, she's so cute.
Wait, I love her design.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I really like her.
I really love her hat.
Because it reminds...
Her hat is really cute.
Yeah.
Babushka is her name.
No, babushka.
Wait, she's a grandma?
All right, that's fine.
That's fine.
She's cute, though.
I like her.
She's cute.
Also, sound guy.
How was it so far?
All right.
Okay.
Wait.
Do you want to consume?
Yes.
I do.
All right.
It's so low.
Okay, I'll boost it up a little bit more.
I still have time to boost it up.
All right.
I can bring up...
After this, I'll bring it up.
Okay, that's fine.
We're having more time.
It's okay.
We're getting the purples out of the way, guys.
We're just getting the purples out of the way.
More work.
Is it for the character?
Let the greatest genius of the century lend you ahead.
Oh, Tensai.
That's me.
Oh.
I don't really like her.
She feels too simple.
I don't know.
I don't really...
Wait.
Is that E?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I love her.
Sorry.
I meant to say I love her.
I was just joking.
She's not simple.
I swear.
You take that back.
She's not simple, guys.
Wow.
Look at all the colors she has.
You take that.
They're good.
Guys, I love her design, guys.
You do not disrespect.
Guys, I'm...
I am...
Let me get my ukulele out.
I apologize.
I've made an absolutely horrible mistake.
But now I've learned that she is the best girl in the entire game.
Guys, I love her.
Oh, my...
Guys, you know how much I love her?
Guys, I will prove to you how...
Guys, please.
No Google Docs.
I will prove to you guys how much I love her.
Look at that.
Oh, let me...
Let me put her in.
Where is E?
Where is she?
E...
There she is.
Look at that.
Oh, that's much...
You know what?
I love her so much.
You get the level 40 gun.
That's right.
You deserve...
You don't...
Oh, there you go.
You get everything you ever wanted.
Guys, look at that.
Oh, my...
Cheetah, you're the one.
You're the only one for me.
You're...
No way.
Oh, my God.
You know how much I love her?
Okay, we'll save this.
I love her so much that...
How do I...
Guys, I don't know.
Where do I get to, like, level her up?
E to the max.
I don't know how.
What do I click?
Oh, it's over.
Guys, I love her so much.
Where is she?
She's so low.
Guys, don't worry.
I'll do it all for her.
Keep...
Click there.
All right, there you go.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I raised her maximum level to 30.
Look at that, guys.
Oh, my God.
Look, I can keep going.
Wait, what is V6?
Clue, guy.
Look at that.
See, I told you.
Absolute...
Look at that.
I would never...
I would never, you know, fuck with her.
Fuck with her.
How dare you?
Look, see?
I'll max level her up.
Look at that.
I'll keep going.
Look at that, guys.
Look at that.
And I'll keep going, too.
There you go.
And I'll keep more.
Yeah, you better.
Look.
See?
Oh, look.
I can't do it anymore.
It's just...
Oh, wait.
I could have done this the entire time.
Subject to commander level.
What does that mean?
Wait, what do I have that everybody is like, what the heck?
Is up here?
Oh, this?
Oh, hey.
Wait, I have her.
Wait, I have multiple skins for her, too, right?
Oh, I do.
I think this one's the better skin, too, right?
Oh, no.
This one was definitely the better skin.
Wait, is she stacked?
Wait, click the...
Where's the icon?
I have to click.
Click this?
What do I do?
Hello?
What do I click?
What?
What is she doing?
Oh, shit.
She's showing me her bike.
Oh, that's cool.
What else can I click?
Oh, my God.
Look at the aura farming right there.
So badass.
What other stuff can I click, guys?
Is that it?
Why are you clicking her hat?
What does she do with her hat?
Oh, is she shy?
Oh, she's repositioning her hat.
Look sideways.
Why?
Oh.
Vroom, vroom.
What are you vroom, vrooming about?
Oh, no.
She's a little crazy.
She's like, vroom, vroom.
I'm like, what are you vroom, vrooming about, ma'am?
What's this?
Oh.
A little.
Oh, and then... Oh!
Okay, I can have her in... I feel like the speed... Oh, wait, no.
Her current outfit's a lot prettier.
Alright.
Oh, I can make her pose in different places.
Concentration.
Zoning out.
Deep sleep.
Pondering.
I think I like.
I like overlooking a lot more.
Yeah, that one's really pretty.
And then, what's this?
Gift?
No, you don't deserve gifts right now.
Apparently, I have to gift... I should be gifting... An E.
Okay.
I understand now.
I get it.
I get why people want me in the dorm... In the dorm now.
Oh, she does, like, different... She does, like, different stuff.
Okay.
Guys, this is for science reasons.
I... Okay.
I was just curious if...
If there was a different... If there was a different pose or anything.
Wait.
There's, like, a new outfit for her, too.
Okay.
Can I upgrade...
E?
Is it possible to upgrade her?
Or...
I need to be sure.
Level up?
What am I missing for...
What is the commander level, guys?
What is the...
What is the commander level?
Click her doll?
Lumen...
Lumen's doll?
Oh, she's cute.
I like her.
Which one's Lumen?
Oh, account level?
Oh!
Oh, so my account level isn't high enough for it.
Oh, I see.
Which one's...
Oh, they're all so cute.
Which one's Lumen?
I don't think I have her.
Oh, so I have to be a higher level to be able to level up her.
Oh, okay.
Where is...
Oh, her.
Oh, there she is!
Hello!
Where's the poses you can do?
Oh, I don't...
Oh, I have to make her level 40.
Okay, guys.
How badly do you want me to have her be level 40?
How badly?
We love our babushka.
Oh, I...
How much do you...
Oh, that's so cute.
It's like a little polar bear outfit.
I like her main outfit more, though.
Okay, wait.
Let me raise the volume up first.
Uh...
Okay.
Sound.
Voice.
Alright, there you go.
Okay, and then I'll raise up the overall.
Alright.
Let me raise up the overall real quick.
Okay.
Uh...
Okay, we will pull for vector.
This is important!
I need to level up our babushka.
Our granny.
I need...
We gotta see what level 40 is.
This is much more important, guys.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
He uses like a pistol.
Level 40.
Granny.
Alright.
And then...
Get to level 30.
Alright.
That's right.
Oh, you're so good.
I knew you were perfect.
Alright.
Span.
Okay.
Alright.
Is she level 40 yet?
No.
Okay.
One more.
Alright.
Now we can see.
Okay.
Alright.
Now we can observe.
Let's see what it is.
This is important.
Oh, it's not that...
It's not that special.
Okay.
You guys made it look like it was gonna be very special.
Yeah.
I'm a little...
You know, all I'm gonna say is that I expected more.
I...
Move the cap.
You don't understand, Toki.
You gotta move the ca...
Okay.
How do I move the camera?
Yeah.
How do I...
Alright, guys.
How do you move...
Okay.
There it is.
How is that more...
How?
How is that...
Top right.
Okay.
I don't understand.
How is that...
I guess you wanna like...
Okay.
Now I understand.
You can zoom in.
Okay.
Now I understand.
I...
Now the fact that I can zoom in...
I understand.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
I couldn't control it properly.
Alright.
From below!
What do you mean?
Alright.
Wait.
I wanna see...
What is it?
Okay.
But I wanna see like...
Guys.
I can't.
Wait.
She's wearing pants though, right?
She's wearing pants.
Okay.
That's good.
I can't.
I gotta go in a corner.
Guys.
I can't.
I can't do that.
Oh.
If you wanna do it, you can tell.
I gotta go in a corner.
I don't feel so good.
I need to go in the corner.
I'll observe in a distance.
In a safer spot.
I'll observe over here.
Okay.
Don't spy on the granny.
Alright.
I understand now.
Okay, so basically, it's like...
What?
I gotta go back in my corner.
I can't... I gotta go back.
Hello, beautiful.
You look beautiful today.
We're not going on the back.
We're good.
Her face is up here.
Guys, her face is here.
Right here.
If you guys want to see for yourself, you don't... Shit.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
The perfect sensor.
Right here.
There we go.
You can do... You can... Click the link in the description and pin... Pin the... In my chat.
To have your own POV.
Alright.
I can't.
I feel like I need to go in the shame corner.
After that.
I can't.
Yeah.
But her feet are... Because thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
I have to go in the shame corner.
For even... Looking.
For even... Oh.
Oh.
I understand now.
I... Next thing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
What color were her eyes?
They were beautiful.
Green.
Alright.
We pulled for Vector.
Guys, we're here for Vector.
Remember...
We're here... We're here for Vector chat.
That... Guys, have we forgotten our main mission here was for Vector, guys.
For...
For Vector, everybody.
We're always here for Vector.
Alright.
This is it.
Yippee!
Oh, it was just for a gun.
That's cool.
Alright.
I didn't realize I skipped.
Okay, that's fine.
We're still...
We still... We can still get it.
Alright.
Here we go.
It's okay.
We're getting out.
You know what?
I'm happy that we didn't get Vector yet.
I'm a little... I might be a little flustered right now.
I'm happy that we're not getting Vector yet.
I need time.
Oh, I already have her.
I mean, she's cool.
Her intro is cool.
I'm re-downloading for Vector.
Alright.
Her intro is cool.
Why is she using a melee weapon in a gun game?
Alright.
Not what we wanted, but that's... I... It's okay.
I'm okay with waiting a little.
Oh, yeah.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
Oh.
Now I understand why my friends were like, you'll see...
when you get to the refitting...
when you get to the dorm.
Alright.
Hmm.
Oh, is it just a gun?
Oh, it's just all guns.
Alright.
Still nothing.
It's okay.
We're just...
It's just building tension, as always.
We're just building tension, guys.
This is where we're actually getting her.
This is the golden light.
Right here.
Right now.
Okay.
Maybe not now.
Maybe...
It's for the content.
We're building tension.
We're building excitement.
We're building...
We're building it up.
Greetings from welcome...
No, no, no, no.
There's no hard pity here.
There's no...
There's no hard pity.
My luck is not that bad, guys.
What do we spy?
I respectfully looked at Granny.
Oh!
Okay, look at that.
See?
Even the game agrees with me.
That it was very respectful.
This is it.
That's how we mean again.
I'm a little happy, I guess.
Is that Vector?
Did I get her?
Oh my god, I got her!
I told you!
My luck was not that bad!
Oh my god.
Does she have to use her feet, though?
Did she...
She's...
Oh, and I get a bonus, too!
Is she...
Yes, she does.
Yes.
She had to.
Oh, she's cute!
Oh, she's here for the money!
I got the 50-50!
Let's go!
Wait, another one?
Oh,
she's like a ninja!
Another purple!
Oh, she's like a sniper!
Oh, nemesis!
Single target damage!
Ooh!
Nice!
I got it!
I told you, guys!
I told you!
My luck is not that bad anymore!
I'm reformed now!
This is where everything goes up for Doki!
Alright!
Anyway, since we're here...
Alright, we gotta...
Where is she?
Where's Vector?
Now that Vector is here...
You know what that means, guys!
Wait, what outfits does she have right now?
It's the free one, right?
Oh, Molotov Bunny!
I believe this is the free outfit...
That you can get from the event!
Okay, bring up the overall, no problem!
Okay...
And then...
Oh!
Wait, turn to the front!
I wanna see!
Oh!
It's like a...
A schoolgirl outfit!
Yeah, this...
The bunny is free!
We gotta complete the event!
Yeah, from the achievement system!
I know there's like a couple of free...
Free stuff you can get!
Uh...
Alright, let's give her...
It's time to level her up!
Alright, level 20!
Oh!
Oh, she's like a...
You tell person!
Boo!
Sorry!
You tell us for weak!
It's for the weak!
Yo!
That's sick!
And she kicks the grenades, too!
I heard she's really strong, too!
Yeah, every doll has a different animation!
You're making enemies today!
I'm joking, guys!
I'm joking!
I love you, too!
Yeah, it seems like her AoE is pretty crazy!
Make her unique weapons and make her powerful?
Okay...
Alright, I got to level 40...
Let me get to level 40 first, guys!
Oh...
Alright...
Okay, we're level 40.
That's the main reason we're here.
Alright, now that we're level 40...
Oh, do I have her main gun?
Change...
I don't, right?
What's her main gun?
I have so many guns, guys!
I don't know...
No?
Oh, I don't.
Okay, I have the...
I have the pull for it.
Okay.
Okay, but that's not the important part right now.
Oh, she does painting!
Oh, that's cute!
What does she do for entertainment?
I just have to be sure.
Sorry.
I...
Deep sleep.
Okay.
I just have to be sure...
I'm reading.
Jesus.
Okay, I mean...
This is like pretty...
It's pretty casual.
It's...
It's pretty casual, guys.
See, nothing wrong here.
Oh, the painting!
Oh, yeah!
I should check the painting!
What?
What are you talking about?
I'm just checking what she was doing!
I just wanted to know!
That's not creepy at all.
That's...
Oh, yeah!
What is she painting?
You're right.
What was she painting?
Let's see...
Oh...
Oh, my God!
Okay, she might have some issues.
She might be a pyromaniac.
Look, see?
This is very innocent, guys.
Yeah, this is...
A very innocent time here we're having.
All right.
You see, look.
What's she reading?
What are you reading, Hector?
What are you reading?
I will never know...
Look, I just wanna know what she's reading, guys!
I just...
Just...
Let me...
Let...
I...
I don't know.
Okay.
Okay, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Ah, ah, fuck.
Okay.
I can't, I need to be in a corner.
I need to be a dog for my sins.
I need to be...
I'm okay.
Alright, let's see if we can pull for...
Let's see if we can pull for a gun, guys.
Um...
Guys, we're here for a gun.
We're here for a gun.
Maybe we can get our gun, guys.
Yay!
Wait, is the gun gold or purple?
Oh, it's the wrong batter?
Oh, whoops.
I...
It's okay.
I wanted that other gun anyway.
Oh, it...
Oh, it's this!
Oh, and there's her.
There's the other girl.
Is it this?
You are forgiven.
It's okay.
I got a cooler gun.
Standard procedure?
Okay.
It's this.
Alright.
Let's do it.
I have enough.
I can pull for it.
It should be fine.
It should be...
You are forgiven.
Oops.
Guys, I don't...
Wait!
What was that?
Wait, I can still look at it from here.
I forgot they're all guns.
So I'm just like...
Accidentally skipping them.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's just a normal gun.
Oh, it's just her purple?
Oh, is that...
I got it?
Oh, I got the purple version of it.
Well, that means I can try another one.
Okay.
I'll just skip it.
What's that?
Oh, I did it!
Yeah!
I did it!
I'm so confused.
I was like...
Why is it rotating?
Why is it...
Oh, that's that easy.
Look at that.
I told you guys.
My luck...
Is back, baby!
My luck is back!
Let's go!
I knew it!
This is all it took, guys.
You want some of my...
Wait, where is she?
Where's Vector?
You want some of my luck?
Just use my link in the description and pin in my chat.
And experience how lucky you can be.
Alright, let's change my gun.
That's her gun, right?
Change.
This is...
Oh, I can like change her...
Her stuff for it, too.
Skin appearance.
Enable...
Oh, wait.
Oh!
Like how...
Different attachments and stuff.
Actually, I like the current one.
If I lose a 50-50...
No blame on others.
If you lose a 50-50, it's because you accidentally took another streamer's luck.
Not mine.
Yeah, you can mod the weapons, too.
Oh.
Does she have like different...
Poses?
Just like...
Oh, there it is!
Oh!
That's so cool!
I like the little animations that you do, too.
Okay.
It's maxed level.
Is everything maxed?
Oh, no.
I can max her up.
Fortification?
Oh, I don't have...
I don't have her stuff.
Zoom in on her face?
What?
Aww!
It's like...
Oh, I love her eyes.
The fact that this is all...
Oh, my God.
I love that this is all 3D.
The fact that this is all 3D is really impressive.
I love the 3D rendering.
It's like...
Look at the detail on her fucking jacket.
Sorry.
Freaking jacket!
Oh, my God.
Like the details and everything.
The models are so good.
I actually really like the models in general.
Yeah.
I heard there's also like...
Uh...
There's the...
What was it called?
The gun room?
Where's the gun room, guys?
I wanna see the gun room.
Yeah, the details are really impressive.
But thank you again for the sponsor.
Public area?
Oh, there it is!
The weapon gallery!
So you get like...
Quick play.
So you can place your guns and everything and like...
Yeah, place your favorite...
Okay, there should be a katana there though.
And then...
So then you have your own little weapon storage here and everything.
Like all the gun nuts out here can like...
Customize what kind of guns they want to be put up top.
And everything.
Oh my god, I have some strong ass guns.
Uh...
My cool ass swords.
Wait, that's just a sword.
Wait, that's not katana.
Yeah, that's just a regular sword.
Oh, and then...
What's the dispatch room?
This is my...
Claim hall.
Yay!
That's right.
Go get your stuff.
Alright.
My...
Oh, then this is where like the true content is.
Alright, let's check out the new event.
I wanna look at the new event.
Uh...
Escape from cyborg.
Challenge.
Supply.
Story.
Lot of play.
Which one do I click?
Oh, reset my troops.
You're right.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter, guys.
Sorry?
This one?
Alright, let's check out the gameplay.
I wanna see what the gameplay is like.
Oh yeah, but is it sound a lot better now?
Sorry, the side quest.
Let's check out the mini game.
The mini game.
Oh.
Okay.
Um...
Obviously I want...
I want her in here.
How do I unselect?
No, I don't want you.
Withdraw.
I want you.
And then I want vector.
There we go.
Oh.
This might be a really bad line-up.
Guys, is this line-up bad?
Put vector and E are in here!
No way.
Their OP is fine.
Okay, that's good.
Alright.
Um...
Go.
And action.
Oh, this is a strategy RPG.
Killer.
Yeah.
Oh, I can kill him from here?
Oh my god, I'm so strong.
Kill him.
Okay.
You know I can't.
I want you to kill him.
Can I kill him?
Can I?
Oh, use auto?
No, I can figure...
Guys, I can figure this out.
And then...
Okay.
Oh, the third skill.
This one?
Oh!
Okay.
Kill him!
Oh, yes!
They're all dead!
Alright.
Oh my god.
Sue me.
Okay.
Alright.
You go out in the open.
It'll be fine.
You'll be so healthy.
What's the worst that could happen?
Oh.
You could get shot.
It's okay.
Stand in the open, Sue me!
You'll be fine!
Like, that did nothing to you!
You're so healthy!
Scale four?
What's it do?
Select one empty dealing equal to all enemy targets within three tiles.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
There we go.
Oh my god.
That's right.
Goodbye.
Oh, it's a freeze-down.
Yeah, it's okay.
Her swimsuit is...
Oh, I'm gonna use ults for everything.
It's fine.
It's only level one.
Yay!
Candy!
Let's just use ults for...
Use ults for everything!
Yay!
Yippie!
Huh?
Oh.
Uh...
Ult time!
Oh, it doesn't matter.
I think she...
Never mind.
Let me just walk over.
Yeah, let's just walk over.
Get closer.
Why are you running?
Oh, wait.
I was supposed to save them.
Oops.
Okay.
Let me head over there and save them real quick.
I forgot my entire objective.
Oh, yeah.
We needed help.
Okay.
There we go.
Ult!
Vroom!
There we go.
I did it.
It's not overkill.
It's okay.
What's this?
Immune to all?
Negative?
Oh, I don't need that yet.
Can you shoot yet?
No?
Okay.
Alright, you should head over and help out the team.
You know what?
Get closer.
Alright.
It's fine.
Nothing's gonna hurt you.
You'll be fine.
Don't worry.
They don't need to shoot.
We're giving them a chance.
What are they gonna do?
Kill me?
I'm level 40.
Just kill them.
Pew, pew, pew.
Yeah, I can do it again too.
Oh, I cannot do it again.
What?
Guess I'm learning.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, okay.
We don't care.
Only...
Okay.
I can read.
Actually, no.
You're so far away.
Okay.
And then I'll use...
Winter's Wrath.
Able to be climbed.
What do I do here?
Moving six tiles to do...
Oh!
I don't have enough tiles.
Get over there!
Move!
Wait, if I go here...
Oh!
And then I can see them!
Nice!
Okay, I figured it out.
Alright.
Pew, pew, pew!
I did it!
Alright.
Guys, I'm slowly figuring it out.
I'm a great strategist.
Oh, it's so far.
Why aren't you closer?
Why can't you be closer?
It's fine.
We'll end turn.
We're too far.
Don't worry.
I'll just be here...
and give you comfort.
I'll just show...
I'll be here next to them...
just for comfort wise.
You go E with them.
Look!
I healed them!
What are they gonna do?
Shoot me?
Oh.
Look at that.
It did five...
It did like one damage on me.
Alright.
This isn't overkill at all.
Yay!
We did it!
I told you guys I could do it.
I'm worried about the loosening of the agreement.
Naturally reaches members of Combat Team B.
They're like little ants.
With Klukai's permission, 404 Combat Team B being led by Vector also successfully rendezvous with the Elmo.
And just like that...
Having...
Whoops!
I actually clicked it.
Having just completed some combat simulation training, the members of Combat Team B returned to the terminal.
The progress bar on the monitor is at 100%.
And dense rows of data and statistical charts start scrolling down.
Vector stares at the final combat evaluation score with a slight frown.
Why are you angry?
You don't look very happy despite the decent score.
Why aren't you happy?
Candidness is a key to effective communication among teammates.
So tell me, why are you dissatisfied with the score?
It's not about the score.
Well Rod, you didn't follow the operation plan we agreed upon beforehand.
A good plan should be flexible enough to withstand change.
As the mastermind behind the plan, I am well aware of this, but since you find it necessary, I don't mind doing a full debrief and review.
The original plan was to immobilize the enemies with a stun grenade after breaking through the door.
Rachi and I would lay down the suppressive fire from the front, while you and Harpsy would circle around and rescue the hostages.
Yes, that's about right.
You are correct, and you did your part.
But your unexpected action affected the whole situation.
Well Rod raises an eyebrow in acknowledgement.
Indeed, I decided to deviate from the plan to eliminate a certain unit.
I don't know why there was a chandelier in the lab, but I bet the interior designer who put it there would be glad to know that their fancy light fixture was the key to our victory.
If there were designers at level 2, that is.
Has it occurred to you that actively altering the environment could put us at a disadvantage?
I think you should make it clear what exactly you're getting at to avoid any misunderstanding.
In other words, scattering glass elsewhere was exactly conducive to our subsequent actions or withdrawal.
Shards of broken glass do no damage to doll frames.
Yeah!
We're not weak!
Yes, but they do harm...
Okay, who cares about that?
Okay, they just harmed them a little bit, okay?
We can fix them up.
We just removed the glass.
It's fine.
They're getting rescued, aren't they?
Pardon?
Well Rod is confused for a moment.
We have no medical dolls on our team.
Oh, okay, never mind.
That's an issue.
I thought we had doctors.
Oops.
Why did we not program these?
Why did we add a code in there?
For them to...
I don't know.
Simple...
CPI training.
If a hostage gets injured and infected under such circumstances, we want to be able to fully complete our...
Okay, that's an issue.
I thought we had like simple med kits or something.
You seem to have overlooked a very important detail.
Our hostages were simulated.
You're right.
But we're in the real world.
Our standpoints would be completely reversed if we don't consider the hostages.
We would be the one who end up in the recycling plant.
Though, I suppose the pain wouldn't last long.
No matter how many points we score in level 2, we'll just be T-Dos whose lives are ruined by video games.
To be fair, that would be quite fitting for me.
Adam, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Hi Toki!
Today's my birthday!
And I took time off work because I might as well be sad at home.
Getting old is cringe.
No!
You get to spend time here with us!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Adam!
Yeah!
Happy birthday Adam!
I hope you feel better!
Also, you should really have notified us before making such a drastic move.
If you looked at the replay, Rachi clearly wasn't aware of your intentions.
And so she couldn't coordinate with you, despite being right next to you.
Even if we suck, we should all suck together.
The battlefield is ever-changing.
Opportunities wait for no one.
Surely you know that as well.
You can't deny the fact that by dropping the chandelier on our enemies, it greatly reduced the threat they posed as well.
As the time it took to mount the rescue, thus increasing the hostage's chance to survive.
Oh my god, you two get a broom.
You guys are still arguing about this.
Even if in the real world, lording at the scene would be more dangerous for the hostages than getting cut by shards of glass.
Like, they're all debating about the one thing for like...
It feels like they've been debating about this one thing for like 10 years now.
But if the chandelier had been rigged with a bomb or a grenade, things would turn out very differently.
Get a room, you two!
So what do you want me to do?
Apologize for something that didn't happen, but could have happened in your pathetic, delusional paranoia?
Ho ho!
Focus on the results, Vector.
Like a normal doll would.
Since the detention...
Oh wait, there were other people in this room?
Like I...
That's awkward.
It definitely did not feel like it.
Toxic Yuri.
Raunchi looks back and forth between her teammates and is about to say something.
Knock knock!
A knock on the glass interrupts the confrontation.
Dolls all look towards the sound.
Commander?
Wait, that's me!
Hello?
I attract my gaze from a screen in the training room and direct my attention to Vector, who has jogged up to me.
What is it, Commander?
Are you here to supervise or training?
No, that's me!
I came to talk to you.
So, isn't the score a bit low for you guys?
Okay, look.
I was learning the controls, guys.
Like, the score might have been low, but like, I was trying to learn.
Yeah, I didn't handle the problem very well.
We have very different habits and ways of thinking.
The judgment process is proving a little challenging.
I don't know if you know this, but rather than adjusting to each other, that sounded more like a full-blown argument to me.
You heard it all then?
Just a part of it, but things are getting pretty heated.
The way I see it, you do work well as a team.
But maybe things may go more smoothly if you communicate in some other ways.
Klukai said as much.
She told me to find an effective way of communicating with my teammates.
But arguing is also a way of communicating, no?
It may be a bit harsh, but through an argument, we can all effectively state our own needs and deepen our understanding.
Okay, but like, arguing a lot is also not good too.
Because then like, you know, you just have resentment and stuff to your teammates.
Cutting remarks also serve as a regular reminder that this position of leadership just fell out of the sky for me, and that I have yet to prove myself worthy.
Well, right.
The change in the way she speaks was a bit dramatic.
But I'm sure, she didn't mean it that way.
I do wonder what it's gone through.
Her tongue is much sharper than it used to be.
It still beats my constant self-pity.
At least she worked on becoming more persuasive.
You see, on top of reaching an understanding, you also need to reach a consensus.
You must also get Wellrod to trust your concern and judgement if you value cooperation.
But right now, both you and Wellrod are still standing your ground, and trying to force each other to accept your respective views.
WE GOTTA PUT THEM IN A ROOM!
WE CAN'T SEPARATE THEM!
Vector was appointed as the leader of 404 Combat Team by Klukai.
It's clear to me that the biggest challenge that stands in her way of being a good team leader, has nothing to do with her combat performance.
The problem is with her personality and style.
Okay, she does have like a sort of resting bitch face, not gonna lie.
Like, she is a bit cold to be here.
Like, you don't really want to approach her.
She fully acknowledged this problem, but that's all she does.
She acknowledges it.
I suppose deep down, even Vector herself doesn't believe that she is up to the task.
Klukai may give her some pointers, but she isn't really the type to give any encouragement.
Sorry, that might have been harsh, since you are the team leader.
I'm sure you have your own way of managing your team.
Right, back to subject.
Have you seen the message that Klukai sent you?
Mechie's training plan.
I will be out on mission with Klukai.
And Doris and Belka are also coming with us.
Mechie's frame is still under calibration, so we will leave her behind on the Elmo for now.
However, Klukai has put together a training program for Mechie because she's worried that Mechie is going to sleep the whole time we're away.
And completely neglect her essential data calibration.
She said you never replied to the message she has sent you, but she's busy preparing for the mission.
So I came in to follow up on that.
Oh, do I have a Mechie in my team?
You want me to supervise Mechie's training?
That's right.
I believe Klukai would like combat team B to bring her along for her training as well.
Don't go easy on her.
Not even a 4v1 or a relay fight.
4v1 would be a bit too...
I've included all the things to note and precautions to take here.
In any case, just make sure her head isn't always attached to her pillow.
Fine.
I hope Mechie won't find a fight against me too underwhelming.
Basically, Klukai wants you to take over as Mechie's leader while she's away.
So don't hold back and be as strict as you want with her, Vector.
I'll do my best.
But only if I can even wake Mechie and get her to attend her training.
I want to see Mechie!
Oh?
Looks like our great team leader has switched careers and becomes a...
Damn!
Well, right.
Oh, she is...
Enemies to lovers!
Let's call it a day.
Submit your reports before 6.
I'll read them through.
After I finish supervising Mechie's combat simulation for today.
Hmm.
Harpsy speaks up a bit timidly from her corner.
What is it?
Actually...
May I supervise Mechie's training?
Huh?
You're actually volunteering for a mission, Harpsy?
No.
I was going to supervise Mechie's training to begin with as a favor of Deer.
Why?
Because the EW training module she is using to debug her data was specially developed by Deer at Cool Kai's request.
I also participated in the development of the module.
Since Deer has to disembarked and return to the safe zone, he asked me to monitor the operation of the module.
An advanced tactical module?
Sounds pretty interesting.
Not really.
It's all...
Oh, she's cute.
It's all really boring.
So, you know, since I'm supposed to be doing it, please let me.
I understand.
However, since Kluca has assigned a mission to me, I must be present.
Harpsy, you're staying with me.
Okay.
I'm staying too.
What?
Why are you also staying, Willrod?
I would love to see if, for myself, what kind of advanced training team A undergoes.
Problem?
No.
If Willrod is also here, then it's all over.
In that case, BB, count me in as well.
I'm sure you have better things to do.
Wait, like...
Assigned her to do something and now that her entire team is, like, part of it too?
Like, what's the point of assigning this?
It feels like a waste of, like, my resources.
I want to spend more time with you, BB.
Please?
Suit yourself.
Just make sure you submit your reports by 6.
Oh.
Yay!
Completed my mission!
Alright, confirm.
Yeah, but they want to be closer to get there.
Alright, so that was the event story.
If you guys want to check out more of this story for this particular event, feel free...
Like I said, you can check out the...
Check out the link in my description and pinned in my chat.
If you guys want to learn more about this story.
I don't know, like...
Oh.
I know there was, like, a minigame section too.
Do you guys know where it is?
Where's...
Uh...
What's supply?
Oh, is this a minigame?
Not at this event?
Oh, no minigames at this event?
What's supply?
What is this?
Oh, it's for the event currency?
Alright, let's see what auto is like.
Alright.
Combat start.
Alright, I'm curious.
Okay, how much better are they than me?
Guys.
They surely can't be better than me.
My amazing gameplay.
Oh my god.
Okay, they're all dead.
Oh.
Alright.
Maybe the game knows how to play the game better than...
Maybe.
Okay, just a little better.
Just...
Just a little bit better, guys.
Wait, it's done?
Wait.
But she's not done yet.
Okay.
Alright.
Maybe the game knows...
Knows how to play better.
She's...
What do you need?
Alright.
Now I know.
Now I know, chat.
I learned.
Okay.
Good job.
You finished it.
Apparently, Kluka is all I need.
Apparently.
Okay.
Anyway.
Let me...
There's something else I wanna...
So, apparently there's like...
A new achievement system.
And then the accessory function.
So like...
How do I access the achievement system?
It doesn't even need kills.
It just hits.
I...
Okay.
Alright, guys.
I learned.
Okay.
I learned today.
Oh, this is a time...
Okay, so this is like all the new stuff.
Oh.
Click on commission?
Okay.
Commission.
Oh.
Oh!
Claim.
Expansion drill.
Journey with this.
Claim off.
Boundary push?
Okay.
I'll try a boundary push.
Where is that?
Is this?
Uh...
Team is ready?
Wait, they're presets though.
I want Vector.
But Vector is so cool!
She's so...
Kukai was so strong!
Use WSD to move your doll.
Okay.
Oh wait, I'm actually moving.
They're explosives around them.
Put them to good use.
There we go.
That should explode.
Yay!
Wait, I'm gaming.
Okay.
Right here.
This is...
Okay, that's overkill.
That's a little overkill.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, whoops.
I'm on fire.
Okay.
I couldn't help it.
Let me just...
Point blanket.
Real quick.
Oh, is this like a stealth game?
Okay.
I'll shoot in between here.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Whoops.
That's a swap.
What else?
Sorry, but...
Maybe I shouldn't have stood...
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Maybe I should have stood next to her.
Alright.
It's okay.
I wanted to use the sniper anyway.
I...
Okay, she's stronger.
Phew.
Easy.
What I thought explosions hurt, guys.
I know now.
Guys, I know now.
Explosions are not good.
I think you just can't do it while inside.
Then we maybe simply move around.
Okay.
I mean, I've been like moving.
Oh, dry.
Oh, they can't detect me if I'm in there.
It doesn't matter.
I'm still gonna kill him.
Phew.
Oh, doesn't know where I am.
Yoink.
There we go.
Phew.
Yeah, he hurt.
Doesn't know.
Phew.
That's right.
Oh, shit.
How did he know?
Oh.
It knew.
Ew.
Sentries don't have ears!
They're robots!
Alright.
It's fine.
See?
I still won.
I still won, guys.
He didn't actually know.
Alright.
I'm being more careful now.
Wait, what?
Oh, no.
Wait.
Come on.
Boss units cannot be assassinated.
Attacking a boss unit will initiate a battle.
Okay.
Make sure you capitalize and oil barrels before initiating the battle.
Oh, okay.
I can do that.
Alright.
Climb.
Okay.
Yellow barrel.
Can't hurt me this time.
Okay.
Now what?
Oh, now he's angry.
Oh!
I was like...
Yeah?
Oh, he's angry.
He's...
He's not happy with what I did.
It's fine.
Okay.
I have this, though.
I have gun.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Let's go.
Okay.
My two characters might be almost dead because I might have...
May or may not have accidentally stood on some explosives.
Yes.
Please heal me.
Please heal me, guys.
Alright.
It's okay.
She's fine.
Pew pew!
Yay!
We did it!
See, it's just that easy.
How do I get down?
Okay.
Down I go.
What's this?
Okay, it's only level one crisis.
Oh, I can click when the area has been full.
You can tap the evacuation button next to the mini-map.
To end.
Okay.
I don't need to yet.
Oh, wait.
I want to open this first.
And then open this.
Okay, what did I get?
Yay!
I did it!
Oh, that was fun.
I like this game mode.
Alright.
And I got everything.
I should be able to evacuate safely now.
Yay!
Okay, a new point unlocked.
Ooh!
I have so many gold items.
I like gold items.
Yeah, only a little damage.
I should not have, like...
May I have fucked up by standing next to the explosive, but that's okay.
Uh...
That's okay.
Aww!
I'm sending her out, right?
Oh, this is me dispatching them.
Oh!
Wait, I want to see...
Oh, they're so cute!
I want to send Vector out.
Vector, where are you?
Do your job.
Where's Vector?
Oh, there she is.
Do your job, Vector.
I'm not saying Klu...
Klukayo.
That's cute.
I like the use of 2D there.
Yeah, the use of chibi dolls there.
That's really cute.
Um...
But yeah!
Good shout out again!
To...
Um...
Mika and Sunborn for sponsoring me!
To check out Girls From Line 2 Exilium!
I think, honestly, this is my favorite part of the game.
Wait, where's...
There was a girl I really liked.
Oh, she's not...
She's wearing a different outfit.
Wait.
Change outfit, please.
Alright.
Oh, she's so cute!
I love her swimsuit!
Wait, YouTube...
YouTube, would I be okay?
Awww, there's her listening to music!
Awww!
Awww.
Observing...
Deep sleep...
Chill...
Okay, we're not...
Awww!
We're not doing that.
We're looking at her beautiful face.
Okay?
Her eyes are up... Okay.
Her eyes are up here.
It's not... Guys, if you want to experience... If you want to see it herself, guys... If you want to see yourself... What it was going to look like... You can click on the link in my description... And in my chat...
And download Girl's Frontline to yourself.
And check it out yourself, guys.
Yay!
All I'm saying is... The link is right there.
Alright.
Nice.
What are dolls doing?
Check out.
I want to look like... Okay.
Let's... I want... There was like... Where's the cat?
Oh!
The cat girl's cute.
She's cute.
What's her different outfit?
Oh, porn?
Oh!
Okay.
What is...
What are her poses?
Just cute.
Reading.
Observation.
Oh!
She's like... Like...
She heard... Her and fish.
Then there's uh...
And it hurts.
She's playing with the cat ball and everything.
We're observing, guys.
We're observing.
Alright, this is a good... This is good.
Alright.
I... Observing?
What?
We're observing, guys.
You know the problem.
Alright.
But yes, that was really fun.
I had a great time.
Checking out Girls Frontline 2, Exilium, and all the features they had there.
They definitely had a lot of different things you can do in the game.
So, and... Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna say the graphics is actually... I love the graphics for this game.
Like, the 3D is so well... Oh wait!
I forgot to give them gifts!
Alright, give me a sec.
I gotta give... I gotta... Wait, before we call it here, I gotta give the girl... I gotta give her a gift before we go.
Where is she?
The main girl.
Alright.
You want headphones?
There you go.
Wait, can I max it out?
Can you love me now?
You love me now?
What happens?
Oh, there you go!
Love me more.
Yes.
Anything else?
Don't worry, I have more.
Don't worry.
I have more for you.
Nice.
Don't worry.
It's not over yet.
Welcome to the tomato fire.
Don't worry.
I have more.
Wait, what?
I... What?
I can... What?
I can do...
Alright, nice.
I'm level 5.
Wait, is that... What do you mean?
What do you mean?
What do you... I gave you... My entire life!
I can't... No!
I can't... Which one?
Who can?
Guys.
Who?
Oh, I have her.
Oh, my God.
I already... Did I already marry her?
Hello.
Come, take my hand.
And tell me that you need me by your side eternally.
I will forever engrave this moment in my neural cloud to honor this once-in-a-lifetime victory.
What's gonna happen?
I expected this.
After all, there's no way I would yield a place beside you to anyone else.
She's my rebound.
After... After I couldn't get Cheetah.
She's... She's my rebound.
That's...
Like...
That's... That's... That's... Don't... You don't say that.
We all knew who we wanted first.
The same.
Wait, does she have a ring on it?
There's no ring on it, though.
Wait, who's next?
Her?
Wait, is she... Guys, I don't think I have enough.
Oh, wait, I already married her.
I think, right?
Yeah.
Oh, I can do it again.
Oh.
I have... Oh, my God, I have five rings.
I have five.
Gotta collect them all.
Alright.
Nice.
Five wives!
Let's go!
For us, dolls, coming to this world is something we all truly look forward to.
We might not be human, but there's still many wonderful things to experience, even in this messed up world.
And meeting you was the most wonderful thing I have experienced so far.
I hope you'll carry on traveling with me from now on.
Yay!
Two wives!
You know what's better than two wives?
I'm gonna make this world that has the commander in it a better place.
Oh, nice.
I got a...
It's time.
Three.
Alright, where's Mechi?
Someone's like, look at Mechi.
I don't think I have Mechi.
Do I have Mechi?
I don't have her.
She's so awesome.
I already have three.
Oh, my God.
I do already have three.
Oh, I don't have Mechi.
Wait.
Can I pull for Mechi?
It's not too late.
It's not...
Wait.
Is she pullable?
Pull?
Here?
Not right now.
It's too late.
It's okay.
Maybe we can have four.
It's alright.
Don't worry.
It's not too late, guys.
Wait.
Do I have...
She's affinity three.
Actually, no.
I'm not feeling her.
Alright.
Who is...
Who is Hyun...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Let's look at Vepily.
Alright.
I feel like you guys are gonna...
Pondering.
Observing.
Reading.
Alright.
Let's see if we can get her.
Guys, I think I'm broke now.
Wait.
No.
I'm definitely broke.
Wait.
There's still hope.
No!
I can't have four.
I can't...
Oh, wait.
Wait.
It doesn't matter.
Four is all it takes.
Oh, no.
It does matter.
Never mind.
I need five.
God damn it.
I only...
It's okay.
Me and my three wives.
It's alright.
I have three wives and that's all.
Ooh.
Wait.
Is this...
This is the one I have, right?
Which one is this outfit?
Oh, that's so cute.
Oh, they're all so cute.
Okay.
I like this one more.
I think I like the embroidered.
It's alright.
I'm okay.
I'm satisfied with four...
Three.
Alright.
I wanna know what it's like.
Go in.
Oh, she...
Yay!
Make sure you think this through, okay?
No walking it back.
What?
Are you kidding me?
It's too late to regret it now.
This time, I'll follow you no matter where you go.
So, whatever it is, whether it's the black zone or the white zone, I'll make sure you realize this is the most sensible and perfect choice you've ever made.
Oh, she's a tsundere.
Look.
We'll never be separated again after this.
It's not like I was looking forward to this that much.
Yay!
Three wives!
It's alright.
I'm okay with three.
Wait.
Oh, I keep forgetting.
I was like, wait a minute.
There's a...
That's...
I can't marry her.
I can't...
Oh.
It's okay.
We'll put it...
Emotions.
Wait.
What?
Do I have more emotions when I'm...
Whoa!
Oh.
Whoa.
All right.
We'll put it at...
What was it?
Was Saber that was good?
Or was it...
I don't know.
Okay.
We'll put it here.
Hey, guys.
That was a...
That was a great game.
It was nice checking out girls' front line to Exilium for the first time.
Shout out again to Sunborn and Mika team for sponsoring me.
Um...
Oh, you see that?
That's my ring right there.
Or is it...
Wait.
Where is it?
That's my ring right there.
We're married.
We're...
I hope you guys enjoyed the stream.
And I hope you guys check out the game.
Um...
Uh...
Like I said, clicking the link pinned in the chat and in the description helps out a lot.
And, uh...
I hope you guys get a chance to check out the game yourself.
Uh...
Play around with all the different features.
Look into the story as well.
Um...
Thank you guys for coming, everybody.
Uh...
Again, thank you again to the sponsor.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that...
Blood Flour.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next...
Wait, let me...
Let me give you...
Okay, here.
I'll give you guys a little.
Okay.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Don't say I didn't give you nothing.
Bye, guys.
Bye.